let's say that i have a circle my best
attempt to draw a reasonably perfect
circle
so
there you go not too bad
it's a little bit of a hairy circle but
you get the idea so this is a
this is a circle this is the center of
the circle and let's say that i have an
arc along the circle so i'll do the arc
in green
so
i have arc that is part of the circle
and it subtends an angle so that's my
arc
right over there
and it subtends an angle
and the angle that it subtends so when i
mean subtends you take each of the
endpoints of the arc go to the center of
the circle
go go to the center of the circle
just like this and so it subtends angle
theta right over here
so it's subtends angle theta and let's
say that we know that angle theta
is equal to two radians
so my question to you
is what fraction of the entire
circumference
is
this green arc what fraction of the
entire circumference
is this green arc and like always pause
the video and give it a go
all right
so let's let's think through it a little
bit
so you might say well how do i know that
i don't know what the radius of this
thing is i don't i you know how do i how
do i think through this and we just have
to remind ourselves what radians mean
what radians mean
if an arc subtends an angle of two
radians that means that the arc itself
is two
radiuses long
so this right over here so let me let me
let me make this a little clearer so if
this
if the radius is r
if this radius we do this i already use
that color if this ray i have trouble
switching colors all right
if this radius is length r
then the length if this if this angle is
two radians then the arc that subtends
it is going to be
two
radiuses long so this length right over
here is two radiuses
now what fraction of the entire
circumference is that well the entire
circumference we know we know this from
basic geometry the entire circumference
is 2 pi
times the radius or you could say it's 2
pi radii 2 pi radius this is 2 pi radii
is the correct way to say it so what
fraction is it it's 2 radii
it's 2 radii
over 2 pi radii
over
2 pi radii
2's cancel out r's cancel out and so it
is one pyth i guess you could say it is
one over pi
of the total circumference